There are many theoretical reasons for believing
that there is much more to our universe than
the part that we can see.
And this idea is called the "multiverse."
It's the idea that there are other pocket
universes far beyond what we can actually
see within our observable horizon and that
those universes could have very different
properties to our own.
So this is almost like science fiction.
When I first heard about this idea, I thought,
"It's not testable."
I'm an experimental scientist and if something
can't be tested, for me it remains theoretical
or speculation.
So when I met Matt Johnson and he suggested
to me that there was a way to test this idea,
I became very excited.
Because we have to be very lucky to be able
to test this idea, but if it can be tested
— it's discovering another universe is an
amazing thing.
And the way that this could be tested is that
very early on, when these bubble universes
are very close together, they can collide.
And that collision can cause a perturbation
or a bruise in what we see in the very earliest
light in our universe: the cosmic microwave
background.
So we've developed these algorithms to try
to extract such a signature from this data.
While we were doing this observational program,
we realized that the predictions for what
the signal should look like should also be
revised because when these collisions happen,
it's a very violent event.
It could actually cause the destruction of
one of the bubble universes.
The mathematical techniques that we had to
try to predict that signature were not enough.
We learnt that we have to put Einstein's equations
for general relativity on a computer and do
this problem numerically.
So that's what we did.
We actually simulated whole universes in the
computer.
We collided them.
And we were able to extract the observational
signature.
This now allows us to carry on this observational
program for looking for this signature, and
I'm very excited about that.